[Musique]
premier proverbe répétant qu'il s'est
mis à rim est donc tout le monde sait
qu'on reste à la maison était tranquille
que ça va faire du bien à tout le monde
finalement c'est pas parce qu'on a peur
c'est parce qu on est prudent la
prudence par bravade
mais c'est une belle vertu c'est
beaucoup d'intelligence dans l'action de
la fois bien sûr de l'espérance on ne
commence pas s'affoler
et puis de l'amour ne pas en contact
avec les autres ne pas les toucher le
pas et c'est assez ce sera pour nous de
marque d'amour puis enfin loisy vite et
à la maison d'un oubli ça on fait des
actions c'est le moment d'aller vers
l'essentiel et l'essentiel nous autres à
sa façon à bout cette épidémie en
évitant les drames et la pénurie de
places dans les hôpitaux restent
confinés restons chez nous et respectant
quelques péter craig pas trop compliqué
labeaume où les mains régulièrement
tous sont dans le coude ou dans des
mouchoirs jetables bardot une distance
raisonnable entre nous mais alors qu'on
va aider quelqu'un et les embrassades en
ratant
j'espère protégeons nos aînés protégeons
les enfants protégeant les veines
protégeons tout le monde les gens
comptent des mêmes ce qu'on habite à ne
pas agir ainsi
[Musique]